at the beginning of this season i
announced that i was going to go back to
get my high school diploma
because i don't have enough on my plate
and i thought what an optimal time
i'm not alone in this journey though the
reason i wanted to do this is because
it's honestly a personal insecurity and
a bucket list thing that i've wanted to
face at different intervals of my life
so i figured why not now just do this
and i have my back to school crew with
me and i'm so excited because they're
here in person today
please welcome anisa
back to the show my dear friend justin
and linda
justin i'm so happy to see you again
happy season okay so justin i'm just
gonna tell you he saved um a family from
a burning car
saved their lives is a complete
superhero wears a cape came on the show
we got carmelo anthony to like because
he's a big basketball fan do a video for
you
and then we talked about the ged
together and it got my wheels spinning
so
here we
are um it's been very hard for me but
hey i got the motivation of everybody so
now anisa um i really appreciated your
story you got pregnant when you were 17.
um but you are 32 years married to their
the dad yes still married to the same
guy 32 years later so what was sort of a
life-altering moment became your
beautiful permanent love story
oh most certainly and
i got the three most amazing kids in the
world out of it so i have no regrets at
all i mean certainly i mean of course i
wish i would have gotten it earlier but
look i'm here now so well i mean i think
i'm in the same boat you know i love my
life and wouldn't change it for a thing
but this is something that just for some
reason haunts me as something it feels
like that dirty little secret and it's
just because we know we can do it and we
should have done it well linda you know
your story also really struck me too
because
in your bio i was reading at one point
in high school you fell in with the
wrong crowd
oh yeah really quickly well i can't
relate to that at all
yeah i let's face it in high school i
was up to completely other things yeah
and then your daughter
goes into the military and kind of has a
completely different narrative totally
different just
she is amazing my lala she is 68 whiskey
combat medic
go arnie
[Music]
so she actually
she
enlisted right after she graduated and i
think it really was kind of a thing with
her that um
you know i i want to further my
education which was actually the reason
for her enlisting do you think that you
guys talked about that with her growing
up was it absolutely it just was always
with her you know in conversation like
don't do what i did get an education get
a degree don't work this hard and
obviously that really resonated boy did
it ever oh yeah yeah very proud of her i
mean
what do you think justin do you have
that feeling ever like because i don't
have this
degree or when i'm thinking about my
future
or there's something missing that people
might think there's something missing in
me i do feel like there's a part of me
that that i am missing that's that
graduation that's that diploma cause my
older brother or sister got it and i
think that's the main thing that
probably motivated me the most because
uh i'm the
third child on my mom's side so it's
kind of like i gotta get it after my
older brother sister if i don't then i
just feel like i'm just letting
everybody down so now you guys are on a
text chain right oh my gosh
okay can i get in on this text change
please
sorry because
i'm not gonna lie
i i have a pit in my stomach over this i
am nervous which is why we started the
touch chain because it's like um i for
me it's like oh my gosh is this person
like smarter than i am am i gonna sound
dumb if i'm like hey i had to do on that
question
like
i'll tell you
comparing is toxicity it is don't ever
compare yourself to other people in this
world and this life i'm learning i
didn't need to go to school to learn
that
[Music]
you